hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play
Lakeview cabin a lot of you guys have
been like begging me to play this one
and I put it off because I was busy with
other stuff but now I'm going for it and
from what I've seen I haven't seen any
videos of it but it looks like a
pixelated style game but it was a guy
this guy's standing naked on a pier so I
was like what's going on but anyway okay
so it is pixelated style game I can go
in this house okay that does nothing I
lay in bed and stare at this picture of
my wife oh how I wish she was here
Oh was away to bring her back there no
no just don't about my business sorry to
start off this game so yelling Lee but I
can pick up a box and that's something
worth celebrating
I guess the next can I have that no not
the box I don't the box I want the axe
there we go oh there we go [ __ ] Boosh
what was that was that BAM oh I seem to
have bees all over my face I'm not too
worried about it
woosh woosh need to find what else is
this so that's a piece of wood what is
this no not that this what is this oh
it's by knock you Lars I got by knock
you Lars wait what do I do about that
what do I do oh it's a deer do I need to
kill that deer somehow beware of the
Beast okay anyway Wow alright then oh
great now my control scheme is reversed
why I think this is the Pierre that I
was standing naked on I believe Hey look
at that the bees went away still all
drunk and stuff yeah what is this this
is generator why do I need that
stop going all wonky [ __ ] Oh
oh great I'm naked oh boy this is this
this is what I saw everybody this is
what I saw this let's go for a little
dip that's enough that's enough
I don't need any more than that one more
would be cool that was refreshing
ah that was delightful is it what did I
just take a drink I'm gonna put my
clothes back on thank you very much okay
here's another box I I think I can smash
this one open to one of theirs another
useful item in here other than the buy
knocks the buy knock you Lars okay
drop this no don't throw it just drop it
yeah what is in there what is this
Wow with the flashlight that's awesome
this is incredibly useful this is
incredibly useful maybe I don't know
some people have said that this is a
horror game so I'm waiting for the
horror to show up what do i do what do I
do
I don't know what I do I'm not sure what
I do
hi babe when I usually see a sexy ghosty
lady I usually go running towards it but
something tells me that's a bad idea
such testosterone enrage only I had a
woman to release my tension if you know
what I mean huh uh-huh
tired of swinging my own axe carving up
my own wood if you know what I mean I
guess I'll just go to sleep
am i asleep what is going on here what's
happening excuse me pardon me
what wow what are you doing what are you
doing there just pondering life oh I
miss my wife who misses so much I don't
know why she wouldn't join me on this
lake in the middle of this lake in this
island what was I saying I don't even
know what I'm saying anymore
nothing makes sense oh well time to get
up I guess who needs sleep little DEMA
truth the eggs okay wait a minute
Oh am I supposed to kill that deer come
here I'm gonna kill you oh that doesn't
look good
yeah give me I'm recording a video right
here I don't take you kindly much to
your notifications of tech I am busy so
what am I supposed to do I don't get it
am i just a dick dad would that's what I
think are you what am I supposed to do
what am i doing I don't get it am I
supposed to throw myself into the ocean
[Music]
excuse me pardon me what the hell is
going on oh really oh really
maybe I'm supposed to throw stuff into
the ocean you like my sacrifices ocean
monster take it all even my naked body
what is this it's an outhouse oh I don't
know what I expected I seem to be take
what was that did I see something but is
there something up there wait no no no
no no no I see something up there
there's a key up there how do I get that
don't stop taking the doors for two
seconds and get the key I see it right
there there's a lock the cabin like
right here this one how do i how do i
how do I do that
do I take this in there and throw it no
throwing no pingas it's right there Oh
what did I do
I didn't
ah I just what how is that a thing how
do I get that what was that
excuse me who's there who did that
what's going on someone be [ __ ] with
me what was that what's happening yeah
I'm gonna get you who cut this anyway
who did that
how do I fix that what do I do okay no
thank you
[Music]
electrocute yourself No
well alright then I sure wish I had my
axe it seems mildly menacing that seems
a problematic
[Music]
yeah suck on that [ __ ] oh she's still
coming jeez oh I wish I had my axe I'm
just gonna hide in the outhouse you'll
never find me what are you are you the
ghost of my wife okay that's that's no
good should I get naked for you milady
I'm so confused and concerned you'll
never find me
holy crap oh my breasts Oh to summon her
what does that mean what does that mean
Rezo to summon her what I want to do
that
oh I'm pressing oh oh there she is
oh well that's not what I I did I didn't
want that IIIi don't know what I
expected
you're ready baby
[Music]
oh oh I done goofed
I'm just gonna drink my troubles away
you can take it here you like this baby
how about some of this how we are still
alive well I'm just bleeding a bit go my
meat that did not go well Dennis oh and
into the ocean I go what is that dolly
[Music]
alright let's do some let's do some
planning here yeah leaves on the face
don't throw my axe into the ocean okay
no big deal
it ain't no problem for me how do I get
that I'm gonna bring my axe in there try
to swing swung it make them fall down
how do I get that I want it I see it
right there hey let me put that there
I'm not gonna summon this over this way
if this would maybe I can put this
wooden like here hey there we go okay
now what I'm gonna do
relocate this to here get on this
this seems what what happened going to
the bathroom for two seconds just get
the key I see it right there I don't
know what to do I don't know what to do
come here dear oh hi hi lady wife lady
Chris Otis oh there she is
oh that did not work
how about I okay you just drink that you
drink that honey honey bear oh god I am
need to get my axe lady how do I get it
how do I get it I'm just on the toilet
did my own business toilet nothing's
gonna happen to me
[Music]
god I don't know why that still got me I
do is coming alright one last try to
figure out what the hell is going on
here one last try one last try maybe I
maybe I don't destroy this but instead
take this with me go to the bathroom
pick it up look I gotta do something
with this what what happened there Oh
once again I don't know what I expected
alright I'm all bloody now well I made
this easier for my wife got some bees
for ya know what to do there's a bucket
here why didn't I use the bucket
what is the bucket for maybe I put the
bucket here and look yeah there we go
now what now I can do something with
this I don't know what but I can do it
now what okay
I'm adding 2 plus 2 what would I you
it's a bucket for what could I possibly
use the bucket of water for what the
hell did I just do I splashed the bucket
on thumb but why why why why maybe I
need to splash it on her no don't throw
it in the ocean thank you very much
flusche got that okay now I go what do I
do let me summon her oh that did not do
oh did it I know what I need to do I
need to cover in water and then shocker
zapper oh I got this I got this I got
this 100% unlock oh I got this I just
need to uh I need to fast forward until
it's night so let me just stick around
for a bit and to like do it thank you
yeah it's good dole and even though I my
wife died in the war and I lost my son
to typhoon fever and everything died in
every way possible even though there was
a zombie apocalypse and the rest of the
world at least I'm still hearing
breathing the natural there has never
been so good to be naked out on up here
oh I hope my wife doesn't come and
suddenly kill me but that's okay yeah
but I'm never dumb enough of me out yeah
there we go
now we got it now we're rolling now
we're firing on all cylinders now we're
doing nothing now we're going to the
prom
now we're getting up and getting out now
we got our morning coffee
now we're gonna shock zap this lady in
there yeah here she comes
I'm ready for you baby remember when I
used to give you a showers every day
don't misconstrue that I don't mean that
in any other way who's got it
oh my god that is an alien oh wow all
right then let's take two I guess I wish
I could make this thing fall didn't I
make it fall down like running it over
running by it with not this not this but
this I yeah there we go it happened but
how do I not make that be oh there we go
[Music]
let's do this like to stage all right so
now that we got that there we put this
here this over here but this here we're
getting ready for this I'm gonna I know
there's got to be a way to like set that
trap so I have an idea
I gotta have everything that I need
right here axe right here bucket of
water right here I'll chop this line
then I'm gonna set this somehow maybe
just yes yes oh crap I did not plan that
correctly crap crap sir okay good
there's a box in here I did not plan
this out there we go
last light just in case you get dark
it's gonna be there no not that
okay wait hang on everybody just hold
your horses gonna bring this on put that
over there then I'm gonna summon her
wait no yeah yeah no yeah no yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay here we go
let's do this hey baby how you doing no
good look good you look good babe
don't know what you're doing with an
alien inside yeah I told you that new
diet fad was no good for you
I tell ya eating parasites there's no
way to go about dying
you look great the way you was just not
right now okay that's the most that I'm
gonna smack her and then I'm gonna get
this but this here take this throw that
over there throw this whoa I'm ready for
you baby I'm ready for you I guess I
need the lawn mower that would be the
most logical why didn't that work I
thought it was gonna work fine fine
you know what fine you know what I'm
just gonna find how it's gonna be now
we're gonna do this don't care it's all
right I'm okay how about you maybe I
need to use the bees the axe didn't work
lawnmower didn't work or the law of the
trap didn't work I'm just assuming the
lawnmower it's going to work maybe maybe
I need to burn it with fire with like
the booze oh come here baby
uh hurry up god you're gonna went on the
new diet but you didn't exercise at all
you're still just as flabby as before
reversing sorry to do that baby
sorry I got it in her hair a bit I'm so
sorry
you know what screw it I'm gonna be
naked for this I'm on do this someone do
it naked
total freedom this is my land I get to
do whatever I want
are you ready I'm ready you ready I'm
ready
you ready
well fantastic
ok here we go I got I'm this plan B
don't throw bees Adam gonna throw bees
at you baby gonna throw a lot of bees
get ready ok that's good I guess
now first time I'll throw a log at you
then I my for bees it you see which one
works best after that I got no course of
action
oh that did not work is he not working
on oh that did not work either
Oh what
[Music]
did I do it we didn't know I needed to
pick it up but now I'm naked it's by the
dead corpse of my wife dad some that's
good I guess now feeling too good but at
least I'm naked now what I got you baby
no you ain't struggle out on this one
well that buys me some time but what do
I do besides it
that's an annoyance now Oh God
[Music]
now it's all new Darden's dumb okay you
know what you know what I'm gonna throw
you into a trap I can't just get you in
a trap I'm gonna throw you into one come
here yeah not all you get away from me
no I don't you don't need oh god damn it
okay I don't know I don't know what I'm
gonna do
I ain't got no clue I don't know how to
beat it I don't know how to do this so
I'm just gonna leave it here until I
find out what the cheat code right now
okay all right okay all right I was on
the right path I was doing it correctly
but I just didn't do it I didn't execute
it
I didn't execute my plan I have an idea
though because this is actually it's
actually a way to do it that I'm gonna
do that's probably gonna be easier and
that's to throw it off [ __ ] her into a
fire good good get out of my god
whatever you know what whatever whatever
whatever whatever it don't matter I'm
just gonna have an extra one that's all
I'm gonna do I was on the right path
throwing it into the bear trap would
have worked but apparently it didn't
decide that I wanted to do it Oh get out
of my way
you know what budget budget budget
no come here lady no I can't believe I
was on the right path the whole time I
almost had it I just didn't do it fine
whatever
[Music]
yeah let's take this with me what's that
do I ever hear a diabolical monster
coming after me OOP oh all right come
here lady
I mean kid there we go oh that sounded
like a bit what oh ah come on I don't I
don't seem too good I seemed very big
well that took a long time for a very
short thing I can underwhelmed by that
oh so much oh well all right then
apparently the three ways you could have
killed it is with the lawn mower which I
tried but it barely didn't take two with
the bear trap but apparently I didn't
get it right or I died right before I
could get to it and three throw it in
the fire that's what I could have done
there you have it that's Lake View cabin
it wasn't bad it was actually pretty fun
but I just don't know what else to say
that's all so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go yeah
No